A weekend of
chaos and drama in Russia.
With mercenaries declared a mutiny
and then called it off.
In under 24 hours.
Why then would see that
Yevgeny Prigozhin
issued a call for rebellion.
The head of the Wagner mercenary group
accusing
top Russian
military commanders
of gross mismanagement
of the war in Ukraine.
Then Prigozhin released
video of an alleged Russian airstrike
on a Wagner camp in Ukraine
demanding revenge.
Russia's defense ministry
denied the attack,
and soon Russia's top
prosecutor announced
criminal charges against Prigozhin
Then in the early hours
of Saturday, Prigozhin
followed through on his threats,
sending his fighters
across the border
from Ukraine back into Russia.
Footage
surfaced at dawn showing
Wagner fighters
surrounding the military headquarters
in the southern Russian city of Rostov on
Some locals
stood nearby watching some U.S..
At around 7:30 a.m.
Prigozhin was
then shown
dressing down
senior Russian
military leaders and issuing demands.
This would appear again.
We came here.
We want to receive the chief
of general staff and sugar
until they show up until they show up.
We are located here
blockading the city of Rostov
and will go to Moscow.
The
video showed columns of Wagner troops
heading north towards the capital
along the way,
claiming control
of military installations
in the Voronezh region.
Footage later showed at least one
Russian helicopter
narrowly avoiding a missile collision.
So was wrong with you?
At 10 a.m.
Moscow time, Russian
President Vladimir Putin
made a televised address to the nation,
calling the rebellion a stab in the back.
All those who deliberately
chose the path of treachery,
who prepared an armed mutiny,
who chose the path of blackmail
and terrorist methods will face
inevitable punishment
and will answer both to the
law and to our people.
The Kremlin announced counterterrorism
measures, tightening security in Moscow,
but by Saturday night,
suddenly a Kremlin reversal.
Putin's spokesman announced a deal by it.
The more we knew,
Meier Prigozhin released
an audio message saying
his troops would turn around
and go back to field camps
to avoid shedding Russian blood.
While
their supporters chanted
Wagner as fighters drove out of Rostov,
giving Prigozhin
handshakes as he left in this SUV.
The Kremlin says it's dropped
charges, and Prigozhin will go to Belarus
while promising his fighters contracts
with the Russian military.
For now, a crisis apparently averted.
But this very public betrayal
and the mercenary short
but unimpeded March on Moscow reveals
deep weakness
at the heart of the Putin regime.
Ivan Watson, CNN.